was war sonst immer so etwas mal so
geführt
das war schon von einem minute dahin
forderung dahinten punkte das ist etwas
dabei der lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal
ich bin ich und sandra f cell fisahn
reinster kann bitte abonnieren
das habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon bei
studien bern unter anderem gesehen und
wieso hat es dort auch schon hochgeladen
es geht darum dass und jetzt auch genau
es geht darum dass ich gleich ein wort
sagen und dann muss sandra ein nächstes
wort sagen wann ich wieder an bord und
wir müssen zusammen einen satz bilden
und wir machen das so schnell es geht
wir müssen so schnell wie möglich ein
wort sagen und der erstes verkackt dem
nichts einfällt oder der stadt oder so
derartig halten - punkt das kleid da auf
jeden fall wird dann der verlierer am
ende der wer mehr minuspunkte andreas
öfter verpackt hat einen satz zu bilden
der wird am ende einen shot wodka
trinken müssen also für luca eine
bestrafung für mich eine beförderung nur
vorstelle müssen und möchten der
allerdings euch sagen dass ihr definitiv
keinen alkohol trinken werde dass
alkohol ab 18 ist und dass man das immer
in einer
einem gewissen rahmen genießen sollte
wir sind allerdings beide beachten und
ich hab gar for life und klar so david
dobric alter in jedem block saufen und
nehmen die drogen und alles sollte
trotzdem sagen alkohol genießen
responsibility und wir fangen jetzt was
wir zu sagen ich bin jetzt frei teilte
ist das spielen so lange bis 15 ich bin
ein alkohol ist nicht gut weil es immer
für geschlechtsverkehr nacht den groß
sonnenbrand ist sexy weil ich das noch
kann als sexy weil ich gegen meine hosen
sind folge schiffen mit schalke aber ich
denke dennoch nicht vorhänge sind
wichtig weil man dich dann nicht sieht
ja cola ist lecker weil ich das sehr
gerne
außerdem ist ein meer und skateboard
fahren ist echt schwer weil ich das
nicht kann aber ich mag dennoch das war
schon da sei schon sehr lange gewartet
ein halber minuspunkt
umweltverschmutzung ist scheiße weil die
tüten dass man zwei wirtschaft
sandra rott heißt ja nicht so gut wie er
gut da steht ja unter wartet mal wer
morgen um sechs uhr morgens arbeiten
muss um eine universelle würde mir das
heute wieder jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wir haben
wie gesagt bei andern youtube an dieser
ein wort challenge gewinnen und dachten
uns dass wir auf jeden fall ganz lustig
wenn der verlierer dann keine ahnung
die jelly beans es muss oder so werden
wir halt die wodkaflasche gesehen und
sandra kegel alter als erstes die
hierher gefahren hat das gerne mal einen
daumen hoch da unserem podcast jeden
donnerstag kommt um 18 uhr eine neue
folge popstars online von sandra und mia
sandras jetzt auf jeden fall ein
bisschen angetrunken und damit schreibt
zwar gerne die kommentare was ich das
nächste mal besondere aufnehmen soll und
jetzt kommt das auto check
[Musik]
ich vergesse anzusagen